And the teacher had already instructed her to stay out of the boys' bathroom.
And she had drank two glasses of that red juice
at the Halloween party,
and I mean, who can resist that red juice, right? It's so good.
And she couldn't hold her pee any longer.
Her and her classmates were four years old.
They already felt empowered enough
to police her use of the so-called public bathrooms.
She was four years old.
She had already been taught the brutal lesson
that there was no bathroom door at preschool
with a sign on it that welcomed people like her.
She'd already learned that bathrooms were going to be a problem,
and that problem started with her
and was hers alone.
So my friend asked me to talk to her little daughter,
and I did.
I wanted to tell her
that me and her mom were going to march on down
and talk to that school, and the problem was going to go away,
but I knew that wasn't true.
I wanted to tell her that it was all going to get better when she got older,
but I couldn't.
So I asked her to tell me the story of what had happened,
asked her to tell me how it made her feel.
"Mad and sad,"
she told me.
So I told her
that she wasn't alone
and that it wasn't right what had happened to her,
and then she asked me if I had ever peed in my pants before.
I said yes, I had,
but not for a really long time.
(Laughter)
Which of course was a lie,
because you know how you hit, like, 42 or 43,
and sometimes you just, I don't know, you pee a little bit
when you cough or sneeze,
when you're running upstairs, or you're stretching.
Don't lie.
It happens. Right?
She doesn't need to know that, I figure.
(Laughter)
I told her, when you get older, your bladder is going to grow bigger, too.
When you get old like me,
you're going to be able to hold your pee for way longer,
I promised her.
"Until you can get home?"
she asked me.
I said, "Yes,
until you can get home."
She seemed to take some comfort in that.
So let's just build some single stall, gender-neutral bathrooms
with a little bench for getting changed into your gym clothes.
We can't change the world overnight
for our children,
but we can give them a safe and private place
to escape that world,
if only for just a minute.
This we can do.
So let's just do it.
And if you are one of those people who is sitting out there right now
already coming up with a list of reasons in your head why this is not a priority,
or it's too expensive,
or telling yourself that giving a trans person a safe place to pee
or get changed in
supports a lifestyle choice that you feel offends your morality,
or your masculinity,
or your religious beliefs,
then let me just appeal
to the part of your heart that probably, hopefully,
does care about the rest of the population.
If you can't bring yourself to care enough about people like me,
then what about women and girls
with body image issues?
What about anyone with body image stuff going on?
What about that boy at school who is a foot shorter than his classmates,
whose voice still hasn't dropped yet? Hey?
Oh, grade eight,
what a cruel master you can be.
Right?
What about people with anxiety issues?
What about people with disabilities or who need assistance in there?
What about folks with bodies who, for whatever reason,
don't fit into the mainstream idea of what a body should look like?
How many of us still feel shy
or afraid to disrobe in front of our peers,
and how many of us allow that fear
to keep us from something as important
as physical exercise?
Would all those people not benefit
from these single stall facilities?
We can't change transphobic minds overnight,
but we can give everybody
a place to get changed in
so that we can all get to work
making the world safer
for all of us.
Thank you for listening.
(Applause)
Thank you.